you made I thought a hilarious joke at  the Oscars you were going to announce  the winner  you opened the envelope and you realize  that it's Alejandro Inarritu who has who  has won and you said who gave the  son-of-a-bitch his green card and it was  hilarious and you guys are friends but  there's then there's this blowback  people think how dare he say that what  was your response to the criticism about  your joke well they could be a bit more  cheerful I think they'd you know there's  that thing where because within that  part of our society that is in idiocracy  the up D of what they do recognize is  the latch on subject matter who he said  this and I can put that in a category  where if I criticize it I'll have a lot  of friends on Twitter for a minute right  and and so they did and and and you know  it gave them something to do right right  [Applause]  you